all right hillary clinton is finding
even more bizarre ways to be in the
spotlight tonight teaming up with the
group of master class to teach what she
is calling quote the power of resilience
and in the class clinton read what she
says is her 2016 would-be victory speech
it's been over five years since her
crushing loss to donald trump but
hillary still can't move on take a look
i dream of going up to her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
now that is powerful
not really of course those baffling
remarks immediately prompted
predictable mockery across social media
one twitter user writing quote she'll be
teaching you how to wipe an email server
with a cloth
another quote is this a master class on
avoiding wisconsin peddling collusion
hoaxes paying russians to meddle in our
elections deleting emails or being a
sore loser and hillary does your speech
mention anything about 18 usc 793 that's
the espionage act does it mention
anything about the leading subpoenaed
emails or paying for the dirty russian
uh steel dossier that was used to spy on
your opponent donald trump here with
reaction author of the bestseller laptop
from hell fox news contributor miranda
devine along with fox news legal analyst
greg jarrett uh i don't even know
miranda what to make of that except you
know i'm i'm a for a little less crying
on television now
of late between her and baldwin i can't
take it
i mean it's quite hilarious and what's
most hilarious is that she's build this
as some sort of master class i think
that people are supposed to pay for and
it just looks like a master class in
self-pity and delusion or maybe a master
class in how to lose an election um that
speech is just shocking and you know you
have to note that she's you know very
emotional about this loss from five
years ago but
she wasn't as emotional she was quite
callous actually when she was testifying
about benghazi so i i just look at those
tears and they leave me cold i normally
feel a little sorry for people who are
overcome by emotion but not in this case
because it's so
self-engrossed
what'd you take craig jarrod i mean
i don't even know what to say about this
the fact that we now know still lied it
was an unverifiable of ironically
russian dirty dossier used to spy on her
political opponent and that transition
team and a president and she got away
with it and she used it to distract from
the email scandal the server you know
like
that she wiped clean and had her devices
busted up with hammers you did it
miranda did it i did it we go to jail
she does it nothing
yeah hillary could teach a master class
in cluelessness i had the misfortune of
watching all of it it was pathetic and
embarrassing
and actually nauseating i kept thinking
what kind of a person does this well a
person who yearns for relevance to be
sure
but an embittered person who refuses to
accept personal responsibility for her
own failure she lost
because she ran a hideous campaign with
unpopular policies and came across as
unlikable and yet she's obsessed with
blaming others she wrote an entire book
blaming everybody else but herself you
know people like this sean you know
can't stand defeat they can't stand
criticism she seems like a classic case
of narcissistic personality disorder
this overwrought sense of entitlement an
exaggerated sense of self-importance and
no sense of self-awareness but on top of
it as you point out scandal in
malfeasance follows her everywhere she
goes miranda's right she didn't give a
damn about the murdered americans in
benghazi she said what difference does
it make she invented and financed and
disseminated the russia hoax and lied
about it she insisted she did nothing
wrong in her email scandal and lied
about that and her her so-called charity
well that's a quid pro quo personal
enrichment scheme
so you know hillary clinton sewed the
seeds of her own demise when she looks
in the mirror there's there's no
reflection there she's like the picture
of dorian gray who sold her soul and
destroyed herself
pretty amazing stuff uh anyway greg
jarrett and miranda devine thank you
both